my name is Chen Tom and represent a
company called leaf energy great thank
you thank you guys and the i was i first
came to this country as exiled students
from from china right after kinnaman
swear to follow Marissa because that's a
very good history summary that when I
first came out of China carrying on the
cause of Prague democracy and human
rights movement after Tiananmen Massacre
the first thing we did was the sending
fax machine back I mean promise you'll
remember this is ice age technology that
before and during the Iranian Revolution
and certainly for the Central European
Eastern European country son fax machine
so Justin communicate only a few years
later was founding from number of
private foundations and national
endowment for democracy my foundation
which I found it after I was exiled
academic mr. Jonathan were sending
internet modems back but the speed of
the web and what what enables especially
in the last few years in terms of the
web acting as a social network social
network web has has a bad past any of
this what I will call traditional
concert ever
today even within the four walls of the
great China intranet people get so much
free information much more than we could
ever do by sending in modems and and and
and bring a free mind the journalist in
hydros out of China to get free
information and the chances of free
exchange of firm of our paintings and so
that's that's that's no news to people
in this room when I want to talk about I
get to the topic for this session which
is so the best practice for culture
educational contents and community as we
see it that the central point I would
make is that really they think the the
greatest power now is a wet as a West
spread cultural and social cultural
phenomenon and social force and so I'll
talk about the web first I mean you this
is then thanks to friends so is all
young
well we all know that this is the the
world that's at the center of kids and
young adults there is it's a center of
their entertainment their information
their cultural resources and their
education so that's just way it is and
Frank have Marissa to point out a lot of
examples of today's kids being able to
use education to us much more than a lot
of it worked most of their professors in
fact that library archives are competing
with Google I mean this is common is not
something unique to educational cultural
institutions and you look at film
studios music labels are competing with
web offerings so here you'll see some
couple of strange characters I know
today everybody read Chinese but i was
still translate that's kool ad which is
a chinese word of crisis it's actually
made up by two characters also one is
danger that this opportunity so that the
creative translation of Chinese work
goes but you know let's stay was a good
story that that's what it meant the web
presented opportunities as well
challenges it says opportunity here what
I'm going to talk about is at them what
made Yahoo or Google and Amazon and eBay
those successful web offerings and all
wikipedia has a non-commercial efforts
successful is equally available to
everyone that means it's equally
available to traditional cultural
education institutions and and being
sort of playing the catch up game if you
look at the the what that would be left
side of the screen actually there are
certainly newcomers advantage so instead
of being on the defensive side everybody
can ensure harness the power of this way
and when I talk about the web here is
not so much the end use and the web as a
cultural phenomenon but instead rather
the set of technology is evolving
technologies and social forces that
enable the web to be the way it is come
upon the panelists pointed out is really
a hard to talk about best practice when
we're still trying to understand what
the web is and what is it what it's
really doing but here are some some
initial attempts i will stick my neck
out to to it hardly for criticism and
discussion and as you can see on the
screen here there's a set of things that
among we fin is installs and
partnerships with universities here in
Asia in other parts of the world and
with commercial entities TV stations
including weg & and the PVS world that
the kind of experiences we may want to
learn that lesson or two from that some
of this a very high bar but I'll listen
will very quickly intuitive user
experience I just cut to a a product
demo here as as a way of introducing
this concept and about the vpat the
basically you know today if any young
kids in fact anybody if you give them a
bar like this they know what to do
there's no training is intuitive if it's
next to Google and Yahoo and you say
well let me find anything with Warner
let me find anything with American
archive but then maybe not in public
domain let's find American archive
things what we're helping through w here
with an archive project then you can
find all the continents with America
archive and if time allows will show
some of that and and so intuitive user
interface being able to find video pin
you to find all the documents being able
to find all the photos and images just
like that being able to have all types
accountants
universally available and you managed
unified way there may be a good practice
to follow and and there's also the using
the web not only as a way to easily and
include access information such as
Google search which is information in
the form of metadata and reference to
contents but also the content itself but
furthermore it's also the web at the sea
merchant has become the co web 20 or
even web 30 in terms of web as a way to
access to content tools such as online
editing where is talked about and and
cemented linking so that we we talked to
I have not only internal keywords in
term of sentences and a meaning and
community and connection between people
so that's the emerging space is
cementing linking so just some some
quick examples and say well you know in
addition to finding all this information
where its forms and having the digital
masters different versions all of that
to be accessible let's find oh the
project by some popular item to say
Photoshop okay why shouldn't that be a
asset easily accessible and then
furthermore easily launch into your
local environment so that you have a
seamless experience between the web
world the cloud and your local
environment were
you're very familiar with will may even
have a particular attachment to a
particular tool such as Final Cut Pro or
Photoshop and sable find some Final Cut
Pro project for the American archive for
example here we go this is some fun
cultural project and the video that's
automatically aligned for those kind of
editing project that is compatible you
know so so the idea here is some service
is that providing a seamless experience
that is connected to the intuitive user
experience has seen as for self-service
of continuum from finding the
information retrieving them being able
to find various versions and taking care
of the copyrights aspects of that we can
know this would be used for a month
times that when we couldn't because of
rights issues and then have them
seamlessly load it into a local
environment and back so this is the the
in a computing science space where he
said really the browser driven best
hopping decoration so so that's another
aspect I mean this is certainly a high
bar but that's the direction to try out
I just want to show a example of that
maybe it's a illustrate a point I'll
show Final Cut Pro example of that and
see here or take a quick quick look at
how this works so let's say if you if
you log in and search for Final Cut Pro
project this is something we're actually
in the process working with us at the
center and chlamydia mercy to put in the
Columbia or archive and other archival
environment and immediate environment
which is that once you find the you do a
search and then you'll find Final Cut
Pro project if the reason that we use my
own video clips is in addition to
shameless self-promotion is that I
assume I have rights to use the
interview I did that it's my portion of
it on CNN so any case as you can see the
erse there's one button there's no it's
it's a poor pointing arrow if you didn't
read the manual most kids don't like to
read my
any more you press that what happens if
you haven't have final cut pro in your
environment the production project will
walk out of the cloud and into your
local environment that's a seamless
self-service experience so now you can
see there's a timeline right here so so
now you can be in the comfort of your
local trying to cut pro editing
environment so what's next I mean you
know anybody who uses final cut pro or
motion or whatever the local creative
tools you know that's that's something
that's a very local experience but the
browser Italian browser will make this
at the web scale in from of shareable
collaborative process so because of
search engines right there let's say if
we want to make that continue to produce
a project you can find all the photos
and images and audios and videos that
you may use for example this is actually
with Asian University national taiwan
university its award ceremony for the
affinity in NTU so let's say we use that
for the affinity marketing montage so
you see here you can seamlessly
one-click lumps that's the name of this
function we call of that content again
into your local production environment
so you're 13 clumsy or your production
project which is shared at the web scale
and you're one big launching your
content into that environment so what
happens next what happens with a avid
user of this editor they finish I think
they do it on timeline the combined cool
videos as you can see as long as they
finish they save and render and produce
a new digital master as they call it up
so they don't do anything see that the
key thing here is they don't they don't
really learn anything new they're using
Twitter familiar they are using Google X
search but end result is a web-scale
seamless self-service for a next level
of of the web and social network
behavior which that you know now you see
the project is saved if you log in
somewhere else where the same place a
couple days
later your lunch you know what happens
right you pick up exactly where is the
last edit her laptop so this is seamless
integrated into your desktop environment
and this works with all Microsoft in the
be infinity engine with all microsoft
office with 0 adobe creative suite with
so Apple tools and so most of Sony
software tools so just that's just one
example of this kind of seamless
self-service that going beyond the web
world into the local computing
environment next a huge subject about
taxonomy versus focus on me the ability
of having a very flexible system that
can easily say accommodate any
organization what public standard-based
metadata standard as well as wikipedia
or youtube myspace tagging the idea also
is of course self-service intuitive you
know at any any magnetic field on the
fly being able to take free tagging in
as well as a universal archive a
university archive its will experts
hacking in and adding any number of
field and being able to repeat any
number of fields so there's a doesn't
quite involved discussion but the idea
is this being able to have a single
unified environment and imaginative
schema that accommodate both controlled
vocabulary which certainly has a space
even has a place in our world in the
future emerging convergence world in
media even though it's been on the
defensive side and certainly accommodate
the great power of the free tagging we
have seen in Wikipedia among others and
the next couple of things are wrong very
quickly is that you one flexible and
open architecture that's a very high bar
i will talk about that but how do you do
that I think I'll stick my neck how to
say and so I service or the architecture
the web services probably comes closest
in term of being future proof and proven
and scalable today so I want to try to
do that and wherever possible open
source software as well and dynamic
workflow we don't have time to cover
some of some other aspects so the office
that's very involved I prepared half
dozen of use cases including the
American archive that we're helping
again through w/e to do and that's
actually a candy vines African divine
the CTO of WT screen and just show one
instance of how you can have for example
PP Corps that see a PBS and the lab of
Congress jointly made the standard of a
method of standards a enforcing PP Corps
throughout 374 public stations in this
country as well as their upstream
downstream there there broadcasters were
their production companies are producing
a lot of contents for PBS so so that's
the techno taxonomy aspects of it and
being able to manage that Universal
easily there a lot of other aspects make
it multilingual and make that also as a
self-service so anyone choose a language
preference the interfaces changes the
only surgeon Chinese are searching
Chinese you want to search as well and
never likes clan waving so i'll just
show you what what else what I'm
referring to for example are oops just
that so a simple example would be a
change a language preference sale change
the traditional Chinese so usually
interface changes and you can search you
need to be double by so you can search
in languages you can actually search a
mixed language so all the things provide
seamless and intuitive user experiences
but have very very high requirement for
the backhand so I think I will stop here
is that going into some use cases and
what went wrong what worked in variety
of industries we have we have tried in
the past few years with this generation
of web technologies that we built into
an engine they but instead of putting a
NASA destination site like a Google or
YouTube would do with licenses to our
partners and and and customers to help
them to harness the power of the web
from within so that's my 10 minutes
thank